now movies begin with a screenplay
either an original story
or one adapted from previous work and
after so much isolation we wanted to get
to know our nominees so
here are a few things we learned
the writer director of judas and the
black messiah
shaka kings that's my cousin
it's not but in my head he is his first
movie job was an extra on a film called
30 days
directed by jamal joseph a former black
panther
and for co-writer will berson being the
office manager for john leguizamo's
lower east side films
stoked the fire in him to tell his
stories and for co-writer kenny lucas
watching city of god in college inspired
him to be a filmmaker
instead of getting a phd in philosophy
and his brother keith lucas
was in law school when he realized his
love of film
lee isaac chun writer of minari
whose first film job was producing
educational films in new york
remembers seeing e.t for the first time
as a child
standing a wide eye in the movie theater
the entire time
that is so adorable
oh an emerald finale girl
you took time off from playing camilla
bowles in the crown
to write produce direct promising young
woman while
you were seven months pregnant during a
23 day shoot
[Music]
girl you earned the title of that film
darius martyr supported his 10-year
journey
to making sound of metal with a sushi
catering business in vermont
his co-writer brother abraham martyr was
a musician
and composer and co-writer derek c
and france's first job was a friend's
get
rich quick scheme filming dogs faces on
to put on coffee cups called puppy mugs
dairy let me get one of those mugs
yes and aaron sorkin writer director of
trial of the chicago seven
he started yes
he started his career in movies by
ripping tickets
and making the popcorn in his
neighborhood theater see
you never know the guy serving the
popcorn could be the next aaron sorkin
and the oscar goes to
emerald finale promising young woman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god oh they said write a speech
and i didn't because i just didn't think
this would ever happen and i'm going to
be in trouble with steven soderbergh i'm
so sorry
i don't want him to be cross with me um
oh my god he's so heavy and he's so cold
[Music]
so the only speech i ever wrote was when
i was 10
and i i uh i had a look to see if
there'd be anything useful
from it but unfortunately mostly thanks
zach morris from saved by the bell who
was my very
uh supportive husband unfortunately
uh he hasn't been as as much a part of
my life as i'd hoped
and so that speech is not that useful
but
all i can say is trying very hard not to
cry which is very difficult
as an english person because i don't cry
ever
this film was made by the most
incredible people in the world who made
it in 23 days
just and brought their complete genius
and love
and humor to it and i have so many
people to thank i feel mortified that
i'm here by myself when it's
not just my job at all i want to like
carry mulligan for being not only the
most talented
person in the world but the kindest and
the funniest
um i want to thank the producers for
standing behind this film
always and you know never giving up and
um lucky chap focus film nation
the cast and the crew the greatest in
the world um the kindest in the world
they just made me look good and again
i'm just so grateful
finally my family mom dad coco
my husband chris um
come on come on our son who did not
arrive until a couple of weeks after
shooting thank god because i was
crossing my legs all the way through
so thank you all so much steven i hope
that was all right
you